ADMIT IT: the best part about crying isn’t
the release, or the raw emotions -- it’s
how freakin sexy your face looks when you’re
all done tearing up.
Hey folks, welcome back to DNews, Laci Green
here!
It’s a phenomenon the internet has so kindly
coined as “ugly crying” - when you’re
SO upset that your face gets all contorted
and puffy and um….ugly looking.
But you know what?
I REFUSE TO CALL IT UGLY.
CRYING IS BEAUTIFUL…..ish.
Okay fine it’s a little ugly.
Funny thing about crying is that there is
a huge gender gap.
Women are much more likely to let themselves
cry than men - clocking in an average of 47
cries per year, while men only cry about 7
times per year.
I actually feel kind of bad for dudes.
CRYING FEELS GOOD.
WHY AREN’T BOYS CRYING MORE????
There are a lot of complicated reasons, but
basically it’s a difference psychologists
have repeatedly linked to cultural norms.
How you’re allowed to express your feelings
differs based on your gender.
For instance, as a culture we find it more
acceptable for men to deal with their angry
emotions by getting into physical fights.
While the gender divides in crying are better
understood, WHY we cry and what exactly triggers
it varies from person to person and situation
to situation.
But the universal experience of “ugly crying”
can be traced back to simple anatomy.
In order to produce tears, the lacrimal glands
in your eyes have to get to work.
Tear fluid is produced with the help of blood,
which comes through thick and fast when the
blood vessels in your eyes dilate.
Normally you can’t see those vessels...but
when they widen up, you can tell they’re
there, alright/ All those tiny little vessels
swelling up to produce your tears make your
eyes look “blood shot”.
But what about the puffy eyes?
This happens because, if you’ve ever had
the absolute pleasure of tasting your own
tears, you’ll notice that they’re really
salty.
The salt causes water retention around your
eyes, causing them to puff up.
Salt isn’t the cause for your ENTIRE FACE
becoming a puffy, bloated mess however.
The reason for that is actually a bit more
complicated - it comes down to your fight-or-flight
system.
This is the part of your sympathetic nervous
system that’s activated when your body is
under stress.
When you’re angry, when you’re scared
or threatened - your pupils dilate and the
adrenaline flows, causing your heart rate
to increase.
Crying is basically the same - especially
if you’re holding your breath a bit and
not breathing steadily, it causes blood to
pump into your face, straining your muscles,
and making your face red and puffy.
Add a nice smattering of snot mixed with tears
and drool and well….you’re a masterpiece,
baby.
Thanks for joining me for DNews everyone,
are you an ugly crier?
Tell me about it down below and we’ll see
you next time with more science updates!